in other news this afternoon the man
stabbed to death on a las vegas strip
pedestrian bridge saturday night has
been identified that is the suspect in
the case but the victim has been
identified as an off-duty police officer
from washington state
the edmonds police department says
officer tyler steffens leaves behind a
wife and two children edmonds is north
of seattle 58 year old freddie allen who
you just saw there he is accused of
murdering stephens detectives say
stefans and another man got into an
argument over petting dogs allen stepped
in
allen refused to appear in court this
morning he faces an open murder charge
we're following that story we'll have a
lot more on that in later newscasts
meanwhile another big story we're
following this afternoon it is the
weather it is breezy outside and sherry
we might water on windy too uh yeah
we're definitely windy john and you can
see the palm trees behind joe out in the
field and a lot of dust too so it's a
windy last monday of march and we were
expecting this a pacific storm is
blowing into the west and that will
change those excessively hot weekend
temperatures we had record-setting
temperatures that were in the 90s in
fact 93 on saturday an all-time record
high for the month of march here in las
vegas valley temperatures now are in the
70s and you can see some of these wind
gusts have already exceeded 40 miles an
hour 45 right now in saint rose parkway
40 at harry reid international so this
is the first sign of change for us we've
had some of those big gusts in the
mountains too up to 65 miles an hour so
not little gusts in the valley either so
we'll keep these winds wind advisories
went into effect 10 o'clock this morning
so we're expecting these gusts 40 45
miles an hour that will continue with
the wind advisories in place also winter
weather advisories for the mountains
we've got rain and snow on the way from
california and you can see there's a lot
of it how much will be left by the time
it hits the mountains of california
remains to be seen but our chances for
much needed showers and mountain snow
coming up in your most accurate forecast
john
sherry thank you very much
developing this afternoon a woman dead
after being shot during a robbery this
was near torrey pines in robindale metro
police say the victim in this crime was
in her 20's officers believe three men
broke into the victim's home friday
afternoon while her roommates were
elsewhere the victim's boyfriend
eventually chased the suspects but with
no luck detectives have not given any
suspect description just yet
it was a deadly weekend on valley roads
metro police are now investigating three
deadly crashes the most recent happened
last night detectives say a bicyclist
was killed near nellis and twain the
victim according to officers drifted
into traffic and was hit by a passing
car
investigators say the driver though they
don't believe was impaired
on saturday an atv driver died in a
crash near lamb and cary metro police
say michael miles was speeding and he
collided with a flatbed truck and then
saturday morning a motorcyclist died
near rampart and lake mead metro police
say the victim crashed into a car as
that car pulled out of a driveway the
driver involved stayed at the scene no
charges are expected
a travel warning for you this afternoon
if you're planning to head to tijuana to
mexico the state department says that it
is seeing more crime and more
kidnappings in the baja region earlier
this month u.s officials suggested
americans avoid remote locations in that
part of mexico the murder rate there
they say is rising and u.s citizens have
also been the victims of kidnappings
officials in tijuana though they're
optionally optimistic they don't believe
that this warning is going to keep
tourists away